bonjour à vous de liver concrètement si
l'ukraine continue à tenir face à moscou
c'est notamment grâce à ce soutien
militaire international
conférence de presse le week-end dernier
volodymyr zelensky quand on lui a
demandé qu'est ce qu'il se passerait si
jamais les états unis le royaume uni et
les autres partenaires de l'ukraine
arrêté de fournir ses armes il a dit
qu'il ne faisait même pas imaginer c'est
avec l'aide notamment de javel un
américain alors britannique que les
ukrainiens arrive à détruire les tanks
russes et on voit que les russes dont le
dôme baston l'est de l'ukraine avance
seulement petit à petit dans une
direction vraiment seulement il arrive à
avancer à prendre un petit peu du
terrain au sud est 10 youm ailleurs ils
sont plus ou moins bloqué par les
ukrainiens qui disent que c'est vraiment
grâce à cette aide militaire et qui sont
très très content de la réunion d'hier
et de la promesse de l'allemagne aussi
qu'elle enverrait des armes lourdes et
les armes que l'allemagne va envoyer ce
sont des tanks qui portent des missiles
sol air et moi j'ai pu constater à des
endroits où moi-même j'étais combien les
missiles sol air fonctionne en ukraine
très souvent des missiles russes sont
abattus très souvent quand on entend que
deux missiles ont frappé par exemple
odessa et bien il y avait peut-être
quatre où cinq missiles en réalité qui
ont été tirés mais les autres ont été
abattus avec les systèmes de défense
antiaérienne ukrainien donc il est
absolument clair que les ukrainiens ont
un usage de ses armes très important
bonjour à l'univers malgré tout à la
russie au continue son avancée notamment
dans le sud de l'ukraine
oui ou du moins dans le sud les
ukrainiennes n'arrive pas vraiment à
contre attaquer et à reprendre les
territoires qui sont occupées par la
russie notamment la ville de personnes
qui est une grande ville portuaire où
hier la russie a remplacé le maire élu
par un maire pro-russe que la russie a
choisi
on il est difficile d'avoir des
informations vraies manderson parce que
les gens ont eu assez peur de dire s'il
résiste à l'occupation russe par exemple
parce qu'ils ont peur de représailles il
y à une ombre cas de personnes qui ont
été pris en prisonnier e ou qui ont tout
simplement disparu
mais il ya des rumeurs comme quoi il y
aurait une manifestation contre
l'occupation russe aar sonne aujourd'hui
donc à suivre merci gulliver vous étiez
en direct de kiev